اتفق المشاركون في قمه القاهره لدول
الجوار السوداني على تشكيل اليه وزاريه
مهمتها وضع خطه عمل لوقف الاقتتال بين
اطراف الصراع كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دلاله تعدد المنصات
الافريقيه بين الايجاد والاتحاد الافريقي
والدولي جوار السودان ومنعكاسات تضارب
المواقف والمصالح بين دول الجوار السوداني
وما مستقبل الازمه وسياقاتها الانسانيه
والسياسيه في ضوء المواقف المعلنه لدول
الجوار
هناك محاولات جاده مصره
ومتميزه مثل المحاولات التي بذلتها
السعوديه والولايات المتحده
لحل الازمه او على الاقل لوقف اطلاق النار
والدخول في مفاوضات لكنها لم تنجح بسبب او
لم تنجح يعني كليا بسبب التعنت الذي ابداه
الطرفان حاولت القاهره هذه المره ان تتغلب
على عيوب المبادرات السابقه وان تجمع دول
جوار السودان معا كلها لكي تتفق على حل
شامل طبعا بموافقه الطرفين السودانيين
المتحاربين هذا الحل يتمثل اولا في وقف
اطلاق النار على الاقل حتى لمده ثلاثه
اشهر
والدخول في مفاوضات والا تسمح اي دوله من
الدول
لاطراف اخرى بالدخول الى السودان او
مسانده اي طرف من الاطراف والا تساند هذه
الدول او اي منها اي طرف من اطراف الازمه
وايضا ان تسهل عمليات المساعدات الانسانيه
للاجئين وان تساعد على التهدئه لوقف طوفان
المهاجرين اليها
في طياره او في ثنائي الكثير من النقاط
التي يعني مختلفه تماما عن سواء كان
المبادره السعوديه الامريكيه او مبادره او
حتى مبادره الاتحاد الافريقي وانما تاتي
في اطار محاوله تبني وجهه نظر حديث او
خطوط عريضه هي محل لدى كل القوه لكن انا
في تقدير الان التحدي بكم في الاجتماع
الوزاري الذي سنعقد فيه وهو من شانه وضع
الخطوط العريضه وكذلك ملامح المشروعه
والتصور الذي يتم تق من قبل مبادره الدوار
السودان لطرفيه الازمه اذا استطاعت هذه
الدول في في الحديث بشكل مباشر بان ينبغي
ان تكون هنالك عمليات مستعجله تتحدث بشكل
واضح عن قيود زمنيه ومناقشه الاسباب التي
اسهمت بشكل مباشر في اندلاع هذه الحرب وهي
القيود الزمنيه المرتبطه بدمج الجيش الدعم
السريع عذرا في الجيش السوداني فضلا عن
ذلك قضيه القياده والسيطره فهنالك قضيه
اخرى ايضا مهمه وهو مصيره للجرايم
والانتهاكات التي ارتكبت طوال هذه الفتره
هذا الدور الذي يعني هو منوط بدول جوار
السودان هو دور متمم او مكمل لهذه الادوار
المنوطه بالايجاد وكذلك الاتحاد الافريقي
ففي الاتحاد الافريقي نجد ان هناك تقاسم
لمناطق النفوذ او لبعض القرارات تقاسم
يعني هناك السودان يتبع لبعض
الكيانات في الاتحاد الافريقي ومن اختصاص
الايجاد فهذه النقطه هي التي ربما خفيت
على الكثيرين مما جعلهم يفسرون ان هذه
المباراه التي يبادر بها الاتحاد الافريقي
وكذلك بعض الساسه الافارقه بانها مبادرات
احتلال وتقسيم للسودان نحن نسال مثلا ماذا
تستفيد اثيوبيا وهي صانعه السلام والتي
تبنت حرفيا وفعليا مبادره الاتحاد
الافريقي مبادره الايجاد الذي كان سببا في
المشكله بين جنوب السودان والاتفاقيات
التي تلك ذلك من مصلحه اثيوبيا ان يكون
السودان دوله ضعيفه هشه تعاني من
الاضطرابات الداخليه وعدم الاستقرار لماذا
لانها بحاجه لمعالجه الانفجار الديموغرافي
الذي تعاني منه اثيوبيا والاستفاده من
الاراضي الخصبه في منطقه الفشكه هنالك
ايضا مصالح اخرى او وجود السودان دورا
ضعيف ومنهره وتعاني من الاضطرابات سيؤثر
بشكل سلم جدا في موقف السودان ايذاء قضيه
تصدر نهضه وبالتالي سيدعم موقف اثيوبيا
فيما يتعلق
بالاستمرار في مشروعها والملا الرابع
والخامس استكمال المشروع بينما انت
تتهم يا تراها بانها مؤسسه عسكريه تجدر
يجدر الحفاظ عليها بما يمكننا من قوات
وكذلك من امكانيات نظرا لاهميه السودان
الاستراتيجي مصالحنا الاستراتيجيه هو في
السلام الذي ينعم به تنعم به دول الجوار
واولها السودان
التحدي الان الدعم السريع راغب كذلك القوه
السياسيه الحاضنه التي يعني تتحرك ايضا
خلفي راغب بان يكون هنالك وضع جديد عن
طريق الملاحظات باعتبار الحرب هي ليست
غايه انما هدف لتحقيق غايه وانا في تقدير
الغايه تتمثل في ان يكون هنالك جيش واحد
لدرجه دعم السريع كل الحركات المسلحه وان
تكون هنالك فتره انتقاليه قصيره وجمعيه
تشريعيه تناقش القضايا الدستوريه
والقانونيه من بعد الشروع في انتخابات
عامه هناك مصالح استراتيجيه طبعا يعني في
مصلحه الجميع في مقدمتها وقف الصراع لوقف
تدفق اللاجئين وما قد يحدث بسببه من تسلل
عناصر ارهابيه وعناصر تزعزع الامن وتدخل
اطراف خارجيه الى جانب هذا الطرف او ذات
مصر وقفت على الحياد بين الطرفين منذ
البدايه وحاولت
الوساطه بينهما سواء منفرده او مع مع دول
اخرى مثل قطر ومثل الامارات ومثل السعوديه
ومثل جنوب السودان
لوقف الحرب والجلوس الى مائده التفاوض